As we begin to explore using Unreal Engine for animation, we need to first look at virtual
production pipelines and workflows to better understand where Unreal Engine best fits into
a project.
First, let's look at a very simplified overall workflow for a production that begins like
all productions, with an idea.
Once that idea is presented, it moves its way through development and pre-production,
and then into production.
For now, Unreal Engine can be implemented in these two production stages.
But new tools will allow Unreal Engine to push its way into areas of the post-production
stage, allow a production to extend the range where Unreal Engine can be implemented into
the production pipeline.
Now, if we look at this simplified overview of the typical animation studio pipeline,
the current workflow usually begins with story development.
That's where the story department and storyboards start charting the course of the project,
with the main beats of the story.
This lays down the track for the production train to follow, but in this way, you really
can't move ahead in production without these core elements being nailed down for the other
departments to follow.
Once the story department lays the track, then production design and asset construction
can move full steam ahead.
This is where all the modeling, rigging, surfacing, or texturing happens, along with
figuring out all the technical requirements involved in creating the scene assemblies.
From there, production goes into creating rough layouts, and generally chugs along to
compose all the scenes for the project before animation and layout send shots back and forth
until the final layout is completed.
After that, everything is transferred over to the shot enhancement track, and you might
start doing more shot-specific work for things like lighting, character or camera effects,
crowds, simulation, and creating mats for composite.
Finally, when all that's finished, you're ready to start image output.
Of course, the lighting and editorial teams have probably been working through comps during
the entire process, but now all the elements should start to come together and get that
final edit completed.
So as we just saw through the pipeline example, there are some practical differences that
manifest as strengths and weaknesses to this approach.
These become pretty apparent in the traditional CG animation pipeline, as it is a very front-loaded
story process that almost requires the project teams to figure out all the main story beats
before anyone can do anything else.
This creates those very silo-centric publishing requirements, and that in turn forces the
editorial and layout departments to step in and serve as the main production hub, leaving
principal creatives to be governed by the results of pre-production once all the elements
are in place.
This makes that the only way to know where everything else is going.
This means there is potentially less interactivity between departments, and that can result in
a rather labor-intensive revision process.
And sure, you can still do things like dailies.
That doesn't really change.
But in the traditional pipeline, it's less tactile, and once a shot is near completion
and the layered renders are getting composited for final output, it's not that easy to see
the finished result and then suddenly have to make changes.
At that point, the artist would have to go back, make edits, and then re-export the shot
through the entire pipeline.
And on top of that, limited cross-departmental or even cross-studio compatibility if you
have partners or more locations can create an even slower iteration process than what
you might get when working in real time.
Here, we start to see some of the advantages when using real-time game engines in your
production.
The story development process is better integrated into production, and as a result, shot construction
can feel more like a live-action production, where the director can be involved in the
entire shot creation process thanks to Sequencer acting as the production hub.
Since Unreal Engine's editorial tool, Sequencer, now serves as the production hub, the revision
process, led by the director, becomes much more interactive.
The finished or near final results from Unreal Engine can be exported or rendered at final
pixel levels, and overall, the entire pipeline becomes unified and more collaborative thanks
to real-time integration.
The idea here being that you can either build a new pipeline from the ground up with Unreal
Engine at the core of your workflows or have Unreal Engine take over the areas that benefit
your pipeline for enhanced efficiencies.
So what does that pipeline look like?
Well, in the real-time animation studio pipeline you see here, there are two colors.
Everything in purple is a part of the production that can be done in Unreal Engine.
Everything in teal still requires the use of a DCC application, but anything that shares
both colors can be done using whatever tool the production decides to implement.
That means the first thing that can change is the way story development works.
Instead of being cut off from production, the story can be blocked out in Unreal Engine
by using the free Storyboard plugins Epos and Iliad from the Praxinos Co-op group.
This can be used to generate storyboards and create a real-time story reel or animatic.
This first change can drive faster scene assembly, concurrent modeling, rigging, and surfacing,
and lead production through a more collaborative and dynamic production process.
Everything works together to create the sequence assemblies.
Ideas can be tried out, iterated, and either kept or discarded depending on what best serves
the narrative direction.
Performances can be captured in the engine, adjusted, and polished by animators.
Cinematographers working together with the director in real-time don't even need to
be in the same room as the project can be accessed remotely by staff.
Performances don't necessarily need to be finished before some of the shot enhancements
are implemented as the departments can pass shots around or work in parallel to achieve
near final renders or a complete and more simplified final edit that doesn't have
to wait for everything to be perfect and now allows for a faster revision process.
Now I just mentioned how animation can be done in the engine and really that's what
I want to focus on today.
We're going to take a deeper look at this area in the real-time animation studio pipeline.
Once character asset construction is nearing completion or totally complete if you aren't
the Unreal Engine toolset for creation, then your teams can start creating performances
that can be captured, imported, and edited using Sequencer and Control Rig.
The current workflow for polishing the performance capture animation is one that lends itself
to nearly infinite revisions and noodling.
Once the performances are trimmed down, you can use the bone matching and blend tracks
to create your assembly.
Then just choose one of two paths for polish.
Either go directly to using the inverse solve and baking the performance onto a Control
Rig character or add in some transform track keys and then bake down the animation to the
Control Rig.
From there, just create the Control Rig's additive transform layers and start animating.
As you work through the animation, you can always bake down a new animation sequence
and then apply that new animation track to see how it's going.
This workflow is one that is non-destructive and allows you to go back to any previously
saved point along the process.
So that finishes up our look at the pipeline and workflows for virtual production.
But before we try the animation workflow out on our own, we will do a few quick review
sections of some core concepts starting with importing animations.